Oh everyone I have a very interesting
game for you this game was played today
it was the India's premier championship
it was around 6 and the star of round 6
is definitely Karthik and Murali mr.
Karthik and Rowleys the two times Indian
national championship he won the under
12 world championship in 2011 and in
2013 he won the under 16 World
Championship so so far mr. Karthik and
Murali pretty much won everything he
could win but this game he's facing a
very strong Indian Grandmaster emotion
Marilla lifts bubble and I'm sure you
all remember mister lally with Bubba
from January 2017 that game in the
Gibraltar Open where he defeated holy
fun in 5 moves after the game who even
said that she lost on purpose but I
don't buy it I mean lollies bobble
obviously on the dead game as I'm sure
you all agree but let's see this game so
Karthik Anne has the white pieces and he
plays efore we have c6 so the car Khan
defends by law is Babu Knight to f3 d5
Knight to c3 and now Bishop to g4
instead of Bishop to g4 White is
obviously inviting black to push d4 but
this isn't that great for black after 92
White's perfectly fine and obviously if
white offered this he knows what he's
doing
so Bishop to g4 we have h3 we should
capture screen captures and now e6 black
got rid of his the LightSquared bishop
he now has all of his opponents on the
light squares and now this dark square
bishop is free to roam in between them
as much as he wants we have Bishop to e2
and here mr. lovak Babu decides that he
would like to be in shadow his dark
square Bishop and I mean okay who
doesn't maybe a better move would be
Knight to f6 or Bishop to e7 but he goes
for g6 immediately and now all of his
bones are on light squares and this
seems kind of funny I'm sure I'm sure
there's something wrong with this I'm
pretty sure you can't play g6 in this
position we have d4 Bishop to g7 and the
Bishop to e3
Knight to f6 now e5 Knight f3 7 and h4
if black decides the Castle kingside
this point is going to h5 and the white
is breaking through through this would
be quite dangerous at the moment so a6
we have Bishop to g5 with a temple on
the Queen Queen to b6 and now catechin
plays queenside castle he's not afraid
of this Queen the Queen is blocking the
beep on the knight and the rook are
still undeveloped so that's not really
going to be a problem we have c5 and
Kartik and disregards the C pawn and the
threat of C captures and v4 and plays h5
he wants to break through on the Kings
side we have a/c captures on d4 and now
H captures on g6 and we have h
characters on g6 of course the knight
cannot be captured because of Queen to
f7 this is checkmate the bishop is
guarding d8 so after H captures an g6 we
have a recapture and now Road capture
sin h8 Bishop captures on h8 and now
rook to h1 the strongest move not
allowing not allowing black to capture
the knight on c3 as rogue characters and
h8 comes with check and more importantly
not allowing this d7 night to capture
the e5 pawn this is a this would be
pretty good for black but I could get
this move in between so we have Bishop
captures on e5 and now rook to h7
threatening the f7 pawn and this Bishop
on e5 is now actually blocking this
Knight from coming to e5 so we have f6
and already you see that those pawns
that were our that were on light squares
have already been compromised and now
this f6 move was a must
black in black is not gonna have fun
playing this position and here we have a
very nice move Knight captures and d5
and what's the idea here well the knight
is obviously attacking the Queen and b6
also threatening Knight captures on f6
with tempo and mr. Lolley Bob captures
the knight captures on d5 declining the
sacrifice would for example Queen to a5
leads to Knight captures and f6 with
Czech Bishop captures and now Bishop
captures on f6 after something like
Knight to c6 there is no time to capture
the a to pawn queen to g3 with the
threat of Queen captures on g6 and made
the follow and after night to f8 for
example rock after Sun b7r up to a 7
rock captures Knight captures and now
Queen to d6 and black is completely lost
here the threat is Queen to e7 check
checkmate and well whatever black plays
so white will either win a lot of
material or checkmate the black King
so after f6 and we have this Knight
captures and e5 would attempt on the
Queen love with baba accepts and we have
Queen captures and d5 again offering now
this Bishop on g5 and hero Alibaba
played a queen to c5 but what happens if
the bishop is captured if F captures and
g5 this actually leads to a checkmate in
three moves with Queen to g8 with check
the knight has the block and after night
to f8 Queen to f7 check King to d8 and
now between captors on f8 this is
checkmate
so after Queen to d5 we have Queen to c5
now lolli bubble offers the exchange of
Queens but this is of course not
acceptable to karti can we have Queen to
Jade with check now Queen to f8 blocking
and Queen captures and g6 forcing the
King on d8 we have King to d8 and now
Bishop to b2 finally getting this Bishop
out of harm's way and now it's black to
play and what do you play here here
black played Queen to d6
maybe probably probably a more resilient
move was king to c7 as as you'll see in
the game the king was forced to take a
walk either way so we have a queen to d6
and now Bishop to g4 and this is a this
is a brilliant move this Bishop to g4
because black was black was threatening
to develop with King to c7 King b6 now
the knight cannot come into the game
with Knight to c6
because rook captures and d7 is a threat
so again this night and this rockin
eight are still forced to be under
undeveloped a king to see seven and now
Queen to g8 again stopping tonight from
developing we have worked to a seven and
it seems that now the night is ready to
be developed but we have worked to h8
and what would happen if black played
Knight to c6 now if he would try this
well unfortunately it doesn't work
because of Quinta CA check and after the
King moves your king is awkwardly placed
on b6 this Knight is you're losing this
night with Bishop characters or Queen
captures so after rook to h8 came to b6
now and this is a very funny looking
King and b6 we have f4 this comes with a
tempo is the bishop can't retreat
anywhere and it's very important that
this this dark square Bishop stays on f4
and you'll see why we have Bishop
captures on f4 and only now Queen to d8
with check and now black has a problem
if you block this with the Queen for
example Queen to c7 you get Bishop
captures and f4
you can't recapture the bishop your
queen is pinned with the Queen you have
to capture the Queen and after rook
captures well this is very unfortunate
you are losing this night it's back
twice if the knight moves you're losing
the knight on b8 and after a move like
Knight to e5 you just capture it and
then grab this knight on b8 you're up a
whole piece this is completely winning
for white so after Queen to d8 Czech
king was forced to go for more walking
King to c5 and here we have before with
check the bishop is protecting the pawn
king to c4 and now Queen to g8 with
check King goes to b5 and now a four and
black has an option here he can either
go to b6 or he can capture the pawn if
he grabs the point with King captures on
a four we have Queen to a to check King
to b5 now Queen to a5 check and after
after King to c6 now rook c8 with check
Queen has the block and now simply
Bishop captures and I for this is
beautiful the
we cannot capture the Queen or the
bishop because it's bent from the rook
and after Queen captures rook Bishop to
d3 is check Bishop to f3 is checkmate
and this is one beautiful checkmate you
know this is quite a checkmate
so after this a4 check a lot of bubble
decided to play King to b6 and after
Queen to d8 check a lot of it Babu now
resigned the game it's similar to the
position we already have had only these
pawns are now on a 4 and B 4 and well
there is no more retreats where's for
the King so in this position allow it
Bob resigned the game
what could follow is what we've already
shown after Queen to C 7 simply Bishop
captures on f4 and after the Queen
captures and rook captures black is
losing a piece after the knight moves
like we said a Bishop captures and after
rook captures mb8 this is unplayable for
black I will just show an interesting
variation for example a King to c7 now
we just push the King back and after
Bishop to d7 threatening a5 checkmate
after black stops this you play b5 and
this is this is a beautiful position
this King can never leave the b6 square
and this rook can never leave the a7
square so this is only something that
might have happened if black continued
to play this game but after Queen to d8
check Bob resigned and a beautiful
victory was achieved by the 18 year-old
Karthikeyan Rowley quite a game at the
moment I believe the current standings
are Karthikeyan is a second in in
standings half a point behind the first
place I forgot who was in the first
place so yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it and well as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here I
would like to thank Daniel Daniel Allen
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it thank
you for watching and I will see you soon